thanks for having me so yeah I lead the
autonomous robotics and perception group
at Boulder it's a rather large Bay Oh a
large prehistoric Bay away from here and
so and I'll be talking today a little
bit about some work that's going on in
my group about robotic perception
especially in challenging environments
like in caves but in also types the
different types environments but before
we do that we have to show a video about
some of the I mean everyone's seen this
video it's like wow what can robots not
do right I mean who here's a robot
assist a few of you okay that's what I
feel everyone I expect and we look at
this and we're like okay well it must be
sort of like hand engineered and stuff
like this and it probably is and state
feedback is nearly perfect you have a
lidar it's they only show their
successful events right so they probably
had a hundred of these videos in which
had failed previously and so this is but
still pretty impressive even like the
arrogance that the platform can show by
putting a chance in the air at the end
and if you look at other types of
different examples for robotic autonomy
this is some work out of Georgia Tech's
auto rally car fairly a few years old at
this point using differential GPS to be
able to drift around corners on this
small type of vehicle I think it's like
a 1/5 scale vehicle and they have
essentially you know like a small
compute platform already on it and GPU
it's all on board except for the GPS
component for for its state estimation
and of course this has hit the news
congratulations I mean this is so
exciting to see really has captured the
attention and imagination of many people
being able to do these kinds of
aggressive maneuvers on full-size
vehicles is even more challenging than
being able to do it on these toy
vehicles like what we do in my group
this is some work that we did several
years back about six years ago at this
point being able to drive these small
ground vehicles on kind of terrain park
types of environments and again every
person in in the room that has done any
sort of research in robotics sees first
okay pretty impressive maneuvers but
also they you can't help but look at the
motion capture system and realize that
even through these types of
Vence you know like being able to jump
in everything like that that the mocap
is providing us one kilohertz state
feedback at almost perfect accuracy what
we would normally ground truth our
perception algorithms against the hope
obviously is to be able to remove all of
the different external types of state
estimation capabilities from this type
of problem and be able to reproduce
these results in wild environments
places where we haven't been before
where maybe we have been but we don't
have any kind of external ground
truthing or fiducia fiducial systems
involved and the that is also a fairly
rosy picture so this is also fairly old
work project tango about seven years ago
being able to do 3d reconstruction with
a simple stereo camera on a cell phone
at real time and what we can see here is
3d models fully fused 3d models of the
environment things that you can then
import into game engines and be able to
simulate physics over right so we can
actually build models of the environment
like what we have here and then be able
to say how would a ball for instance
interact with this environment and if a
ball then why not a car right so this is
the back end if you will to that whole
control system that I was showing about
that car that was jumping on the ramps
and doing the loops this is a physics
environment being similar or simulating
this this model of a car over the 3d
fused model that we had built from
perception right but the huge like
gimmick here is that we're doing that
state feedback through through motion
capture and just to in case you're
wondering well how does this happen you
see these lines sort of like you know
just coming straight from the vehicle at
the front of it those are all different
like simulated worlds what would happen
if I just added a little bit more gas
turned maybe half a degree more to the
right on this vehicle at this particular
point in time those were we call control
candidates and we choose our best one in
a in a sort of framework frequently
called stochastic model predictive
control and that's that's all stuff that
we many of us have seen before right and
if you've been to Accra and this is or I
Ross these are these are different kinds
of capabilities that have been developed
for four years
and yet we still don't see too many
places where we can we can migrate this
to the wild in fact you know like I want
to show like this is actually fairly
difficult to do it's not like mundane
this is a human operator attempting to
drive the vehicle through this loop and
here's a well-paid postdoc nearly
getting his head cut off because of this
car that's going to run into him
yeah and doing some superhuman
capabilities you know on his own as well
so you know and just to recall for you
that's that's like that's a graduate
student attempting to drive that car
through that that loop a graduate
student who I promise you has spent a
little bit too much time driving this
car around because it's so much fun
whereas the computer can do it without
any problem at all right very reliably
and robustly so the question then
becomes where are these autonomous
vehicles I've given you some indication
that you know there's there's quite a
bit of promise that we can see in the
field of autonomous robotics today we
have perception and all of the great
advances that have happened there we
have control and I've shown you some
super human-like types of control and
planning capabilities so where are these
autonomous vehicles and let me show you
another video of you know maybe the
state of the art if you will where you
know everyone's seen this video from the
DARPA Robotics Challenge the finals back
in 2015 of some of the best teams that
build robots trying to field them in
this really high-stakes environment and
having failure modes and that they've
never seen before and not being able to
really accomplish the challenges they
would hope and you see graduate students
and postdocs in this video realizing
that they have to work for years longer
right degrees are pushed out that much
further and I mean the reason why I mean
many of you probably work in different
areas here right some of you work in
perception and you're gonna say these
are all perception challenges or control
and say well inverted pendulum problems
in uncertain or uneven terrain are very
difficult some of you look at you know
different types of humans supervisory
interfaces human factors the ways that
humans are interacting with these robots
providing command
sir planning methods these are all at
fault right so I can't really blame just
one of these components it's because the
interplay between these components is so
complex and it's really a high
dimensional world we're dealing with an
uncertain one at that that require us to
you know give a little bit more research
and is is fairly the the human sort of
autonomous robotics future is still very
far off of course is a perception person
I'm interested actually in this
particular scene does anyone know it
happened in this scene just take a look
yes excellent yeah so there was no
torque to balance the torque that they
were applying and so they fell right
over right and so to me this is kind of
at this interface between perception and
control right it's clearly there's some
there's some sensors here and the sensor
has got this robot to the red valve but
the sensors maybe weren't in the right
place one could argue or maybe they were
in the right place but no no there was
some sort of behavioral tree issue or
something like this that there was no
perception fed back into the controller
that said make sure that your grasp is
actually on the red valve so it fell
over and in autonomous vehicles which is
something that you know it's near and
dear to my heart still you know we we
look at problems like this where we say
okay there's a camera and maybe multiple
cameras and lidar and everything else as
a human we might be saying we could we
could see that this looks fairly you
know mundane kind of driving situation
but with a little bit closer because of
this lens flare that happens right here
as you move forward then there are some
weird effects of the auto exposure on
the camera also revealing that there are
threats that exist ahead of us so there
are just these little tiny like problems
associated with where are you looking
how are you looking and are you actually
taking into account the kinds of things
that could result in catastrophe for you
okay so this is more motivational and
you know this is meant to be able to
scale to environments of
complexity so driving in India never
done it before everyone tells me it's
absolute like you know just complete
sensory overload and what we have here
is how would we be able to program an
autonomous agent in an environment where
we have to like be modeling each of the
possible future directions of this kind
these agents here right so I was just
like sitting in a in a self-driving car
yesterday and I was truly impressed at
the ability for that car to be able to
identify all the pedestrians in the
scene like at one point there was like a
head that was like going into a
subterranean passageway and the car was
able to tell even in there like crazy
rain that there was this person it was
like 50 meters away like remarkable
right but try doing the sort of
stochastic model predictive control over
all future trajectories of these agents
right and then even going a step further
asking questions like is this person
angry can I apply rational models of
motion to this car that he is driving is
this person paying attention is this
sort of like you know on the phone or
just scratching his ear
maybe these vehicles can't turn because
they're weighed down by a certain amount
of load that limits their
maneuverability and also questions like
you know should I even listen to this
stop sign is it visible by are all
parties and obeyed clearly not alright
so what I mean to point out from all
this is that the world is not like this
nice like model a bowl environment in
many ways the ways that we sort of look
at stochastic model predictive control
and the reduction of perception and
state estimation into the inputs to that
control system so the world is not this
you know sort of nice drivable road
where nothing's going to happen or maybe
very few things would happen right and I
know that this next slide might be a
little bit difficult for you living in
California but the world is more like
this right where there's snow and where
different kinds of disabled vehicles
might sit on the road and we have to
start asking you know like can we
actually model every single scenario in
which for instance two versus three
versus five people are out pushing a
vehicle
along the road okay and furthermore if
we're driving in this how do we know
what kind of controller is to apply the
stochastic model predictive control
framework that I was talking about
before requires our knowing at least
some idea about what our friction
coefficients are for instance or how our
interactions between wheels and the
ground are going to work and in really
complicated scenarios for contact
granule granular media or other types of
stick slip conditions like this that's
actually really challenging to be able
to model okay
and so I'm motivated now not by
self-driving cars but by what DARPA is
paying me to be interested in which is
truly a remarkable in my opinion type of
environment the subterranean environment
and so I'm going to talk a little bit
about this now and hopefully connect all
the ideas that I've talked about before
with this so here's this you know
entrance to a cave a fairly standard
cave that we might be required to enter
for the subterranean challenge which
requires our putting teams of robots
into mines tunnels urban underground and
caves to be able to find certain
artifacts what DARPA has claimed is
artifacts which might be things like red
backpacks fire extinguishers survivors
things of this nature okay
sure many of you look at this
environment say I am super excited to
send robots into aqueous environments
right the number one cause of
catastrophe at the subterranean
challenge that just happened and
probably in the future ones was water
falling on a computer and that just you
know the robot doesn't move after that
so the environments look like this where
there might not be this sort of crawler
in here but instead you know there's
going to be small and large types of
obstacles that we have to negotiate in
this environment you could imagine
putting in a ground vehicle but maybe an
aerial vehicle would be a better choice
remember we can send teams of robots in
which means that we can choose what kind
of locomotion we would like even then if
you ever do any kind of quadrotor flying
autonomous quadrotor flying and
something like this you could imagine
things like propwash and sort of you
know the
small obstacles that you wouldn't be
able to see necessarily with a light are
even a very high-density light are
causing some issues right and I also
want to in particular draw your
attention to a couple of features on
this image right here this specular
highlight up here as a result of a light
being too close to the geometry the the
walls here and then also reflections as
a result of just specular specularity
zhan surfaces things that really if you
work in vision then these should
frighten you right these are places
where we don't have very good models and
I'll talk more about that but before I
do I want to motivate just a little bit
more about this subterranean challenge
here we are and the system's competition
we're in soap my team is in so-called
track a which is one of the DARPA funded
teams we just finished this tunnel
circuit which is going in environments
not too different than the one I just
showed but then also that we have the
so-called urban circuit next and then
finally a cave circuit six months after
that this is going to be in February and
then finally a year to sort of winnow
down our methods and then get them to
assign a final systems test event and so
there's also a virtual competition we're
not part of one of those we're just in
this one little track up here just to
explain to you where this sort of
competition is and my role on this team
is to sort of help and chiefly solve
some of the perception challenges
associated with operating in in these
mines and the normal ways that I would
try to solve these problems are using
sensor Suites like this one and
techniques known as sensor fusion a
little bit more than just Kalman
filtering we usually use optimization
based approaches and if you again work
in this field then the difference
between the two is is it's kind of
subtle I suppose but in the end it's
taking all these different types of data
distilling them into data products that
then we can do some sort of estimation
over so cameras they obviously provide
us images which provide us information
on both where we are how we're moving
and what's around us it's very very
useful information GPS if available
gives us only
suit arranging positions encoders might
be on wheels or something or be able to
tell sort of how to impute the way that
the physical model of your robot would
be able to give motion prediction
inertial measurement units which come in
all shapes and sizes but in general
they're useful for rotation rates and
acceleration and finally different types
of lidar solutions which give us direct
depth estimate or measurements on
surfaces in in a 3d space potentially 2d
space although we only use 3d lidar s in
our environment in our environments
again like self-driving cars are the
truth like a very motivational case
right I mean they they sort of pushed
the bounds of what is available for
sensor fusion using essentially
everything that you could imagine they
also have GPS on top of this sensor
suite here for different types of
capabilities and the fusion of these
capabilities provide that sort of really
high highly accurate information right
so that's kind of why I was mentioning
that pedestrian example being able to
tell a pedestrian very far away may not
be only dependent on a camera but also
dependent on on lidar and so it's the
sort of tessellation of these different
sensor nets and the ways that they all
work together that we're interested in
now the one of the chief problems in in
moving a robot in an unknown environment
removing that motion capture is being
able to solve state estimation so in
order to do this one of the typical
tools that's used and well known in the
literature now is visual simultaneous
localization and mapping or slam now the
visual part has a lot of different
methods there are things known as
indirect methods sparse indirect methods
which revolves around being able to
compute features in a computer vision
frame being able to capture a frame from
a camera calculate where there are
features being able to match those
features in time and being able to as
you can imagine estimate how you're
moving against those features in an
environment similar to how we might be
able to do navigation against corners in
this 3d environment let's say so up here
is the sort of features and as they're
tracked across frames and then here is
what we call a pose graph as well as
landmarks
in this environment one could augment
this with a little bit of that sensor
fusion technology that I was talking
about to solve so-called visual inertial
slam which involves both the vision and
the introduction of an IMU that helps us
in places where let's say there aren't
many features like on the ground right
here and also Bo is able to help us sort
of work through places where we might
not have any feature correspondences
between frames and the particular
advantage here is if you get motion blur
right okay so let's just take a take a
moment and appreciate those two sensors
cameras provide us relative pose
constraints that is frame to frame
tracking as well as information on
structure that landmark data and I am
use provide us some strong short-term
spatiotemporal constraints or the
ability for us to be able to sort of
forward propagate our state between
frames that that are collected and
whether or not we may have dropped a
frame because there are no features
because there's entirely motion blur or
maybe it was overexposed those are
examples of places that an IMU is
absolutely critical now there's this one
little problem right and this is sort of
going to get us introduced into the
world of sensor fusion and perception
today which is that if you have an IMU
sitting somewhere arbitrarily on your
robot body and you have a camera that is
also sitting somewhere on that robot
body ideally there's going to be some
static transform between the two right
who here has done a sensor calibration
before okay so almost everybody sensor
calibrations involve moving a rig right
and being able to determine moving a rig
against this fiducial target and being
able to regress certain quantities of
interest being able to get se3 offsets
XYZ roll pitch yaw translation
orientation differences between the two
sensors right being able to capture
maybe intrinsics of the camera as well
lens coefficients for distortion maybe
focal point and central point as an
example okay and this is like what
graduate students have to do every day
let's say that they want to be able to
run one of their perception rigs it's
it's extremely harrowing and
time-consuming okay and you know so so
intrigued
juice is perhaps one of the least sexy
but also one of the most lucrative parts
of doing perception which is that nobody
wants to do sensor calibration and
everyone needs to do it in order to use
most multiple sensors so we made plenty
of papers and a group like different
grants and cooperative research
agreements between companies to be able
to solve these like very particular
types of recalibration problems on the
fly and I'm gonna tell you about one of
them right now but the reason why we
would have to do this is okay fine let's
say you're okay with an engineer doing
that whole sense of rigged dance what
happens when someone out in the field
decides that they would like to move one
of the cameras with respect to the other
sensors on the platform or let's say
perhaps that you're doing some fairly
you know aggressive maneuvers and now
you ran into something or you had a hard
stop and that might actually result in a
different kinds of different calibration
or change in calibration parameters or
maybe something unexpected happens and
as a result yardsale sensors fly and
what you don't want to do is have to
send your car or your rig back to the
shop to get recalibrated because it
needs to continue operating maybe not in
this example but you can imagine so we
were interested in trying to solve a
camera to IMU self-calibration problem
this is very helpful for us as we're
moving in the minds but also was helpful
all the way back when we were working
with Toyota so in this case we want to
compute this camera IMU rotation and
translation let's say that your camera
intrinsics are nice and fine we're not
going to change anything this is hard
because we don't have any calibration
target as we're operating we need to do
this in real time and ease the robust to
these sorts of changes that happen on
the fly and the way that we solve this
problem is by collecting the most
informative motion segments to estimate
the parameters and then we detect an
account for changes that negate older
segments informativeness that is to say
we ask the question is this new
information that we just got telling us
something that disagrees with our
previous hypothesis for where what our
sensor calibration parameters were okay
like I said we worked on this for a few
years and this was the I think one of
the more robust solutions that we can
up with which involves this we move our
we are moving our robot right we're just
kind of evolving and wherever we're sort
of moving through this environment and
we capture a subsample of the motions of
the robot and with those motions of the
robot we take an estimate as to what our
calibration parameters are this involves
some estimates of non-linear
optimization which results in some on
some error right this error is
indicative of what our uncertainty is on
that that those sets of calibration
parameters what we're going to do with
that is sort of store these three
motions and throw those motions as well
as the estimate for the calibration
parameters into a priority queue like
this and as we evolve the robot forward
we're going to be collecting more and
more motions some of which may not be
informative right you can imagine in
this case it's not always that every
motion that you take is actually going
to help you regress these parameters in
sensor calibration and so here's one
example in which the information was not
so great there's sort of wider spread on
what our estimation would have been for
the calibration parameters but we throw
those into the priority queue anyway and
we continue evolving so you could see
that this works until the priority queue
is full right after which we run an
estimation over all the different
motions in this priority queue in order
to get our calibration parameters now we
continue evolving a robot just normally
operating and we ask the question since
our priority queue is full and we have
this new motion information or this new
motion sample how informative is this
motion sample against previous exam
previous motion set of samples and in
this case we can say as you can see that
the there's actually this one is
slightly more narrowly peaked if you
will that is to say it's more
informative it's less uncertain about
the particular parameter that is then
one of the motion samples still in the
priority queue so we bump that out and
we throw it in and re-estimate this is a
way just one particular way that we came
up with that involves being able to do
this online self calibration okay and we
throw away other less informative
samples as we go so the the key takeaway
here is that okay well
we can actually run this robot in in
this environment have somebody move this
move the sensor with respect to all the
other sensors and then be able to say oh
it turns out that all of our previous
sensor calibration or all of our
previous motion samples are wrong
that means the central sample sample now
is telling us that there's been a change
and our calibration parameters need to
be readjusted so you can see this is
actually does work in real time somebody
went and adjusted that and we're still
not losing tracking entirely we have
normally what you'd get at this point
it's like a segfault like none of our
calibration none of our slam solutions
are actually converging but in this case
we were able to recalibrate and move
forward but I'm gonna step back on a
meta level here right so maybe you don't
care about sensor calibration like many
of us we just hope that it can be solved
right but the key takeaway here is that
perception and action inform one another
certain motions were helpful other
motions were not okay and in doing that
we've sort of identified a region that
tells us okay we need to move our
platform in a certain way in order for
us to have robust perception okay not
just that but also probably we need to
be able to get robust perception in
order to know whether or not a certain
action is available let's say we don't
have that there's there there's too much
uncertainty on our map for instance and
that those map uncertainties will
cascade into being able to not having a
very good guess as to how our platform
will work in a certain environment so
stochastic npc then would fail so this
is a fairly like general takeaway that
I'm using is sort of I'm using this one
example that I provided is just one one
sort of tableau if you will for this
lesson I'm gonna launch into another
example of this okay so hopefully if you
if you're cool with you know sensor
calibration you kind of get it maybe
keep this in mind as we go forward so
let's focus again on this subterranean
environment so here's here's our sort of
most commonly used robotic sort of
platform for prototyping it's this
little what we call a park or car
and it's driving in this environment
that's dark just like the mines that we
expect to be operating in okay and what
we've done is we've attached a light on
the top of the of the platform because
it needs to see where it's going right
there's no light and what we've done is
we've also have this camera and what you
see here is the first image is when the
robot was sort of maybe a few meters
further away from it of this volleyball
and now we've moved closer and what
we've done is captured another image of
this of this volleyball a couple things
have happened right we see now that
there's a very direct specular highlight
on the volleyball which means that if we
were to look at this volleyball and say
where are my computer vision features
that might not be so useful you can
imagine because this looks like a white
surface now we've sort of overexposed
all of the texture and features on this
volleyball the second thing is so maybe
that's fine I mean because you're saying
okay well I'm only looking at how this
shifts in the image maybe the colors
will shift in the image the second is
that the the way that the volleyball
looks apparently is different right
which means that any kind of direct
image matching that you would do being
able to say how does my scene look as
I'm moving forward you can't really
apply that anymore because the scene has
changed merely by your motion in it
because you have that light on on top of
you right and this is not an uncommon
circumstance in minds let me show you
the same video of us walking through a
mine here this is the gold King mine in
Colorado if any of you are familiar with
that disaster what we've done is we've
taken one flashlight which is sort of
diffused here walking through this mine
here's another example of us walking
through a mine with a different
flashlight lower setting we've reduced
the brightness setting here where you
can see is a few more sort of shiny
surfaces and a lot more texture okay but
what you also see is that the the throw
of the light is not quite as great right
so you can't really see so much about
the geometry further out and this this
projector is sort you could see a little
bit more than its
sort of reducing some of that that
visibility range and the the final one
is you know if you thought one light was
was just you know maybe will change the
setting on one light for brightness
here's two lights that you could use
sort of one that's focused down into the
the cavern and then one that's sort of
broader at a wider angle to be able to
hopefully capture both of them but that
was even more confusing right we just
were looking at that video and it's like
wow what's moving around me because
lights are moving with respect to one
another the way that the light plays
against the geometry here in order to
create shadows as well as be able to as
the image is being generated show
texture as well as different kinds of
geometry is what we want to discuss so
turns out no one's really looked at this
type of problem before because I believe
no one wants to use visual methods and
caves right I believe visual methods are
sort of what humans can use so I want to
be able to apply those to robots so what
we did was what any good you know
scientist does is say well if I'm going
to be testing any of my methods that I'm
going to be developing here I'm going to
first take a data set so the data set
that we took was in three different
types of environments which I'll talk
about shortly these sorts of caves and a
more urban environment and then an
outdoor environment we also worked in
with different types of sensors so we
captured the data with a real sense deep
435i which if you don't know is the real
sense D 435 it gives us 8-bit gray scale
so 1280 by 720 we had two of these
cameras hooked up 30 Hertz 30 frames per
second data on each one of those camera
feeds the if you have worked with one of
these cameras then you sort of know wait
there's an RGB as well but the RGB is
rolling shutter so we throw that out we
don't use that although we captured it
do you want it we have to I am use one
of them is the one that's inherent on
the real sensitive 435i it sort of acts
like the Bosh I am you in case you've
ever used that one but we don't I've
never torn it apart so I don't know
what's actually on it but it's sort of
like that 250 Hertz and a gyro at 400
Hertz a much nicer
I am you about thousand dollars 3dm gx5
15 from lurid micro strain gives us
actually up to a thousand Hertz
accelerometer and gyro but it's just
much more stable and lower bias drift as
well as as much as we could some
position according to like a total
station I'll talk about that in a sec as
well as a light that we changed the
different lumination settings on and as
you can see here what the sort of
examples of environments that we took
this data set we're in we're a tunnel a
mine a lab and an outdoor environment
and I'll show you videos of those in a
second and okay so let's talk about it
here was the rig we have this like a
prism up here in order for us to get
ground truth for as long as the Leica
laser was available as you can imagine
if we operate in mines and we're going
around corners we can't actually move
the Leica station so that means that
only portions of this pose graph will
actually have ground truth according to
the Leica we have a computer on board we
have the this camera the two cameras
right here
batteries lots of batteries for all the
computer and everything and then the IMU
both in here as well as the Lord
microstrain behind it and to show you
this this light here I mean this light
just a pretty typical LED with a massive
heatsink that would create enough heats
to sort of heat the minds that we were
in with the fan on the back to make sure
that we didn't like overheat the LED
itself so this thing when it was cranked
up was basically the light of day here
are the different environments that we
were operating in here was a steam
tunnel type of environment in our in our
underground at the University of
Colorado and so this was taken at those
different brightness settings different
lumens settings on the on the light and
we tried to recreate the path as well as
possible but as you can see we were
walking around in this environment and
this this does have auto exposure
enabled and the light will be is
calibrated and I'll show that in just a
second so here's the the urban
underground this is a tunnel cave type
of environment that we were operating in
and then finally to make this the
creepiest dataset ever collected
the Blair Witch Project style outdoors
type of runs here so you can see that we
tried to capture a bunch of different
scenarios in which one wanted to do
active illumination and furthermore we
tried to capture those different
settings with different types of motion
blur types of characteristics so for
instance if you're operating at the
brightest setting it might be that you
don't get as much motion blur but at the
lower setting it might look like you
have the same image but there's more
motion blur so those are some sort of
uniquenesses about this data set the
last thing like I mentioned is we did
that light intrinsics calculation
because is if you're wondering what
we're about to do is use the light model
that we can actually try to back out as
a result of this sort of you know creepy
I guess patterning here to understand
how the light is sort of focused in the
scene and then understand how that plays
against the geometry in the scene to
create images and so this is the normal
setup that we did in mainz we sort of
sent these robots collected these data
sets with this rig over here viewers are
like a prism being or sorry like a total
station tracking the prism over here for
as long as we could get it so here are
the remarkable results we didn't just
take the data set we wanted to compare
and see where there were current
deficiencies associated with the visual
slam methods that are available today so
many of you if you've used these
technologies you know that there are
three major competing versions of this
one of them is called okay this or maybe
Vin's mono then stereo
these are visual inertial type of
systems which all of them today rely on
this feature matching that I was talking
about before the next is this orb orb
slam which is pretty much the most
commonly used visual slam front-end
today and that is no IMU only looking at
the only looking at the visual indirect
feature extraction types of matching
stuff and I was talking about the third
is this one known as direct sparse
odometry or DSL so
direct sparse odometry issues the use of
indirect sparse features and instead
looks at those those image intensities
recall how that volleyball changed and
shifted right then we would be tracking
that volleyball over time if you will
and here is let me let me break this
down for you this plot up here so this
is saying the number of successful runs
300 runs in total the number of
successful runs for a particular method
where success is defined by the error in
alignment which is essentially the
number of meters off at the end the
result is right and so you can see that
if success is defined by only being one
meter off at the end then these methods
down here at DSO as well as orb single
orb slam with a single camera those
don't perform so well in fact they
perform they may never actually converge
even for half the runs which is pretty
pretty interesting right also
interesting is that over here there's
this differentiator where if you use a
second sensor stereo or an IMU then you
have clearly better performance in more
accurate performance over time with some
saturation if you will so that that sort
of sort of comports with what we would
probably all expect right we would say
if you add another sensor it'll be more
accurate let me show you the failure
modes in just a second of that what's
also interesting though is it's not just
the that adding another sensor is
helpful it's that if we run the same
sequence forward versus backward in
running let's say like the sequence of
images forward versus running the
sequence of images in Reverse you have
different types of success rates now why
would that be okay let's look at that
for a second so this is that direct
sparse odometry and let's say that we're
starting over here and we're running our
visual system forward visual slam system
forward and this is the sort of
visualization of our map as we're
building it so this is to the starting
point and over here is our ending point
and you can see that even
there's an apparent sort of enlarging
the cave that we are walking in this
doesn't actually happen that's entirely
a result of the errors in the method
right and over here this direct sparse
odometry method if we're running it in
Reverse that is we're starting up here
and then we're running the sequence of
images backward that the scale drift
happens in the reverse direction and the
reason why is because of this notion of
the what's called the brightness
constancy assumption that is to say one
of the most common things in visual slam
direct visual slam is this statement
that if you have an image and it's has a
certain illumination on it you capture
an image after that the illumination
should be essentially the same and we
all know that's not the case when we
have a light attached to the to this
front end which means that pretty much
every method that you run direct on in
this active illumination scenario will
break so all of a sudden you know
there's this huge just gaping hole and
the methods that exist okay and so
here's just this you know another way of
visualizing these results what I may
mean to show here is that DSO actually
has this nice like we would expect there
to be better results perhaps if we were
looking at this dropping this brightness
constancy assumption and of course if
you introduced an IMU then you're sort
of golden right and or a second camera
that sort of also stops this scale drift
from happening and yet direct methods
are still very interesting to look at
from a research perspective we still
want to be able to say okay what happens
if we were to consider using direct
methods here so for instance there's
this bar where this these are the number
of times that orb slam failed in this
one area for ten runs it failed all ten
times independent of the initial seed if
you will and the reason why orb slam
Matar this even the stereo version fails
why there's this sort of on this slide
this asymptotes up here below a hundred
percent success rate is because there's
always going to be a few frames in which
we have complete motion blur that is to
say
we will never be able to capture and
correlate different features from frame
to frame so the point being here being
direct methods don't rely on that and
yet direct methods have is their
Achilles heel this brightness constancy
assumption so we want to be able to
relax that just to show you this you
know another visualization of the kinds
of ways these methods fail here's this
plot this one's probably the most true
to form as well as metric information
associated with one of the runs that we
took and you can see we sort of start
off here we go in then we go down then
back and then over here right and what
you can see is that there's this sort of
enlargen it happens of this pose graph
because of the scale drift from a
monocular system any monocular system
will suffer from this okay with that in
mind we started looking at ways of
addressing this what is this what is the
core of the problem it's that an image
is going to be generated based on
geometry lighting some albedo's or a
natural color in the scene as well as
reflectance the ability for light to be
reflected in a certain way against the
surface okay so what we essentially are
setting up for ourselves is that we want
to be able to use RGB and depth to
measurements that we would have in this
environment in order to be able to do
this solve the slam problem as well as
be able to reconstruct the geometry
densely okay so if we look at the kinds
of methods like direct sparse odometry
that exists today then what we have is
this lightness constant or brightness
constancy assumption or lighting being
the same throughout the scene okay
here's a truth or what this really
should look like and using DSO as well
as these typical techniques that assume
rightness to be constant what we've done
is we see these sorts of artifacts and
these are not artifacts associated with
the rendering these are artifacts
associated with the reconstruction of
the surface itself okay things like just
this kind of wavy behavior if any of you
have used anything like kinectfusion or
elastic fusion dynamic fusion this is
the kind of behavior that you get
when something moves in the scene it
sort of falls off right in this kind of
shaded way so a simple question to ask
is what happens if we actually estimate
what how the the light plays against the
surfaces we're gonna have the light
moving as we're operating in this
environment so here's the truth we're
gonna go ahead and estimate albedo's
that is the color of the surfaces and
here we have a reconstruction which
looks kind of nasty I'm sure many of you
would agree some of it's this black sort
of these are rendering artifacts those
different shadings and drawings that are
happening over the over the image but
you see okay well maybe it's doing a
little bit better in order to sort of
point out to you that I think that
there's is a lot of research to be done
in this field let's look at the error in
the geometry and time where the top is
with the brightness constancy assumption
and the bottom is having sort of relaxed
that brightness constancy assumption to
allow for a dynamic light source that's
sitting on top of the platform and what
you can see is these lighter areas are
where there are greater error from the
ground truth in the geometry and you can
see that this is sort of just
proliferating massively these errors
whereas down here it sort of only exists
at the ridges which is actually where
the geometry is most uncertain so
there's a lot of promise in these sorts
of methods if only we could look at how
we do light source estimation in a
slightly more sophisticated way with
respect to these visual slam methods and
what that means is in fact that I'm
going to recall for you this video what
that means is that with better 3d
reconstructions we can do better control
and planning right because we can do
better reconstructions of how we're
going to be interacting against the
environment and so it's going to be more
reliable and be able to also fill in
these gaps and such without having the
geometry if you will change under us as
we're running an MVC it's huge and so
the last thing is we've been able to
sort of do some other kinds of cool
stuff with this including the estimation
of light source locations which is sort
of doing the same thing as visual slam
except allowing for that light source to
be able to be estimated in real time and
what this has been able to do is so this
is a sort of animation if
we'll of how those light sources those
potential light sources are tessellated
in the environment
we can do semantic segmentation and
albedo estimation using fairly
off-the-shelf type of deep neural
network techniques and be able to
estimate shading and then lighting based
on that which we found to be pretty cool
because now we can actually figure out
where there are actual light sources in
the scene and then understand how
shadows are then cast in the environment
as well and in that case potentially
even invert the shadows so again I mean
this is this is all going to this lesson
of perception and action and forming one
another moving a camera and a active
light source in this environment into a
scene is going to be helpful for us it's
if only we understand how that light
plays against the geometry okay there's
one last example that I want to give to
you in this vein and it's related to
this problem so here we have a fairly I
mean there's some texture on the ground
but on the walls there may not be too
much texture okay so if I'm interested
in using these indirect methods these
feature based methods of tracking frame
to frame we don't even know where we
should be looking right and so I'm going
to use some some motivation from this
this chicken okay so the chicken is able
to stabilize its head which is pretty
remarkable
right okay we've all seen this before
probably what many of us have where the
chicken is there's actually an amazing
soundtrack to this movie that's not
playing right now my apologies but yeah
I mean the chicken what is it doing
anyone want to take a guess besides
gimbley besides biological gimbley
anyone
yeah yeah I mean in a sense it's
interested in this case and trying to
focus on yeah mercedes-benz commercial
for stability in cars interesting
perhaps - okay so what it's doing is its
focusing on a certain feature set in the
environment okay so it doesn't really
like motion blur the chicken doesn't
like motions or it just like our systems
don't like motion blur right but the
chicken is perfectly fine if it just
stays at at like it's gazes on one thing
and it uses proprioceptive sensors to be
able to understand how it's moving with
respect to that thing right because it
understands how it moves its neck pretty
basic chickens are dumb okay so we
thought okay well you know this is this
is a fairly you know this is one step in
the right direction so here we have I'm
just showing you this video because you
know it's the first step if you will
here's this camera that's sitting on a
pan tilt unit and here's the visual slam
solution up here and what you can see is
that it's we're able to track features
on the robotic platform by doing this
sort of surveying right but the chicken
head is not really like remarkable just
because it can serve a well because the
mechanical gimbal could do this sure
many of you have worked with those
before or at least are familiar with
them the chicken head is remarkable
because the chicken moves as it's
looking at something and then it's a
Cod's as its as its heads ability to
remain focused on something reaches its
controlled limit right so in this case
the chicken sort of stabilizes head
moves forward dramatically and then but
its body doesn't it doesn't stop moving
right it has a mission to accomplish
crossing a road presumably okay so
here's the idea right we put the
chicken's head on on this platform here
and what we would like to do is be able
to say stay focused on some set of
helpful features informative features in
the environment landmarks that give me
information on state right and then move
the car around to be able to do what
as you want to do subordinates
perception local planning against the
global mission right so now essentially
what you could imagine is moving this
this robot around and being able to
focus on things and that's the point of
future work that we're working on right
now but what I wanted to show is sort of
some of the simulations that we have in
the formulation that we've taken on this
problem so we've we've reduced our state
vector just a translation velocity and
some biases on the gyro and
interestingly and our interestingly for
us sorry biases on the IMU per time step
kay and what we've done is we've reduced
the camera information to
informativeness on our state vector as
well as informative nasaan landmarks so
this is if you will our generative model
for our camera measurements and over
here sorry for this color that didn't
really turn out so well but here we have
informativeness of the IMU which you
could imagine as being just something
where we're saying well the IMU is going
to give us information anyway so that
means we're going to be moving the
cameras field of view such that we're
complimenting the information we have
from the IMU right and from this we can
say each landmark we can actually
quantify the amount of information each
landmark has as a result of this sort of
total information per measurement okay
we can also do the same if you will for
some future time horizon H at time step
K for each of our IMU measurements and
what you could you what we're going to
be doing is saying okay that means our
total information is our some of the
information per landmarks that are
currently visible in this set s as well
as the IMU information that we get for
free right the IMU is always going to be
operating it doesn't matter what
coordinate frame it's in so here's our
problem we're trying to take the maximum
over possible sets of view subsets of us
within the field of view F subject to
some Co visibility constraints during
the fixation that is to say we're going
to fixate on certain types of regions s
and we're taking the maximum over these
regions s okay and in that region s
there are some landmarks that we can
calculate the information on okay this
requires the introduction of some sort
of information
metric we use the log determinate
information metric on this there are a
lot of examples about different ways the
Fisher information matrix actually shows
the amount of information that we might
have log determinant we've been found we
found to be pretty useful for
computational purposes as well as just
use I mean it seems to represent a
volume of information rather than a
major axis let's say so what we're
trying to do is you know essentially say
if we were given this hallway scene look
at all the features that are right here
that might not be able to provide us
information for very long if we're
moving in this direction but look at all
the features maybe further down the
hallway or perhaps slightly to the left
or right because they'll give us
information that complement our IMU and
we're doing this in a three-dimensional
environment of this so-called hallway as
an example just because hallways are
nice and blank on some walls and have
some features and others so here's
here's a video of that running and what
we have is this simulated hallway
trajectory in which we have a camera's
frustum looking at these different
landmarks in this environment and here's
the visualization in visual slam world
with the IMU being giving us information
as well as the visual front-end actually
being the thing that's pretty that is
processing the images that is the only
component processing the images so we
are able to do here what's I mean many
of you you know you you might look at
this and you say what should I be what
should I be asking the question about
here it's that these are the only
landmarks in the scene
everything else is blank right there's
no landmarks besides these tiny little
panels that we've set up and we're still
not losing tracking because we're able
to look at the panels as we're sort of
flying across them so even in this
extraordinarily visually sparse
environment we're able to still recreate
slam paths or a state estimate reliably
okay so we think that's pretty cool
and we're able to also do it by
selecting sub regions of images in
fairly common tum datas tum indoor
dataset and being able to compare those
rather than doing full count
relations of visual slam against the
entire image which we find to be also
sort of suggesting that these kinds of
psychotic methods are even more powerful
than just say putting up a panoramic
camera and so these are things that you
can see what's coming up next at the
urban circuits so that's February 18th
through the 27th we're gonna be
deploying to SATs op Business Park in
Olympia Washington it's much colder
there snowing they're not heating the
garage it's gonna be great and but
anyway so we'll be up there for 10 days
and deploying teams of robots in similar
conditions to what we've done before
we've had a lot of fun with doing this
and I just want to remark that working
with DARPA and working on these sorts of
projects has been very motivating for
the team and for me it sort of allowed
us to pursue many different research
directions at the same time to have
undergrads and postdocs working with one
another building systems that are not
just you know like caveman type systems
in my opinion they're really like
sophisticated capabilities for mesh
networking for being able to do joint
real local ization being able to do
different kinds of task management etc
and finally also just building out
robotic platforms something that
unfortunately doesn't get done very
often in our field right it's it takes
an enormous number of resources and
hours to be able to build these
platforms but it's been one of the joys
of my first few years of being an
assistant professor at the University of
Colorado to be able to to actually have
teams of students working together
building these platforms and then
running them not only in what DARPA is
interested in but also running them in
agricultural settings different kinds of
partnerships with boulder rescue wild
wildfire management services u.s. Forest
Service hotshots etc which has been a
real fun fun time so yeah we're looking
forward to going out there again just to
just to show off we did actually field
some of our parkour cars in the first
competition we sort of gave them nicer
wheels for for working in mud and here's
a picture of our team and I'm gonna
conclude today by just showing off a
video of our operating in this
environment which is a time-lapse
we're not time-lapse it's the opposite
it's reducing the video to once every
four frames here are some fiducials that
we need to navigate against to make sure
we're in DARPA as reference frame and
again like the whole mission was to find
these sorts of different artifacts and
things in this kind of look at all these
specular highlights different
screwdrivers that are anywhere there's
specular highlights and everything that
would normally cause issues with state
estimators the sort of things that we've
been able to do have really robust to
fied them against dark environments like
this one and being able to operate over
at different types of terrain and and
cooperate with one another as we're
operating which has been like I said a
real joint you know we did fairly well
in the first competition here's us two
marble fourth-place and we hope to
continue moving up in the world Explorer
is cm you know okay everyone here I'd
love to CMU apparently yeah okay and so
yeah I look forward to you know doing
going to the next competition anyway but
I'm happy to take questions and thanks
for your attention
so I'm guessing we don't have time for
questions yeah so right now we have only
pre-mapped environments that we're doing
this against which you might say is kind
of you know how exciting is that
but what we're planning on doing is
being able to just have a very simple
heuristic based on convolutional neural
networks in fact that are conditioned on
the types of environments that we're in
as a prior is different places that we
should be looking but it's the same we
are looking over currently planned
horizons so really all that's the
missing ingredient is where are the
landmarks which can even easily be just
like like I said a prior probabilistic
prior distribution of landmarks which is
what we plan on doing but yeah we are
currently
doing planning over time horizons that
are given to us by planners so in fact
this takes sort of a page out of the I
guess it's Luca Carlo Nate's work on
attention and anticipation and visual
inertial slam being able to say we have
a planner let's use it
[Applause]